the switch 2 or whatever is next might
be further off than we thought plus
we're talking about tiny tina's
wonderlands and more
if you were hoping that nintendo may be
getting close to announcing a new
console you may be surprised to hear
that president shintaro furukawa
believes the switch is actually just in
the middle of its life cycle during
today's earnings call free recovery
shared that the switch had reached just
over 100 million units sold surpassing
the wii's lifetime sales and becoming
nintendo's best selling console of all
time the switch's aging hardware and
ongoing chip shortage that has slowed
down production for all console
manufacturers don't seem to worry him
either he said switch is just in the
middle of its life cycle and the
momentum going into this year is good
the switch is ready to break a pattern
of our past consoles that saw momentum
weakening in their sixth year on the
market and grow further nintendo
consoles have typically been released
five or six years apart so the switch
which initially launched in 2017 is
closing in on what would typically be
considered its final years it's unknown
if furukawa's remarks indicate a longer
than usual way to release new hardware
or if he's simply promising to continue
supporting the switch well into the next
console's lifecycle
good news borderlands fans tinytino
wonderlands has gone gold which means
gearbox software has completed work on
it while the game is ready for publish
there will still be some fine-tuning to
do ahead of its march 25th release which
will likely include the usual updates
and optimizations in a tweet
wonderland's creative director matt cox
commented on the challenge of developing
the game in the current pandemic era of
the world and said i am overwhelmingly
proud of every part of tiny tiny
wonderland's teams we dug deep and
poured our hearts into something special
i love our team and i love our fans
march 25th is so close
wonderland is a borderlands spin-off
that stars the fan favorite explosives
expert voiced by ashley burch similar to
the rest of the series wonderlands will
cast you as one of several classes
berserker clawbringer graveborn
spellshot spore warden and stabo manser
who all wield unique abilities it also
features a multi-class system that
allows for any two roles to be combined
which should make for some interesting
character builds for an idea of just how
gearbox handles the fantasy game you can
check out tiny tina's assault on dragon
keep for pc playstation and xbox the
borderlands 2 dlc is now a standalone
adventure and if your ps plus
subscription is up to date you can add
it to your playstation library as a part
of february's offerings for free
all right let's talk a little bit about
some d make news earlier this week
lilith walter's bloodborne psx d-make
went viral online with crtv grain and a
faithful but creative adaptation of the
game bloodborne's psx's d make is a
delightful spin on the original bloody
combat game well now a d make of persona
4 created by sean ss has just released
on itch dot io sean built the z-make on
the free game boy studio engine and it
is one of his very first projects using
it to play it you can download it
directly on your browser or you can
download the file and use an emulator
sean ss got into d-makes when he
discovered the gb studio engine on his
h.i.o page he told gamespot i was like
hm i can make something cool with it i
thought of making the full game of
persona 4 but then realized that it
would probably take me years to port the
whole game along with the social links
and cutscenes and stuff he also
elaborated on the challenges behind d
making persona 4 on the game boy and
said i think the hardest part for me was
animating the cutscenes since gb studio
mainly uses a kind of block based visual
scripting and it was kind of hard to
make sure all of the individual parts
worked properly as for whether or not
the persona 4 demo d make will expand
into a full version sean ss isn't sure
right now he said most likely the
project will stay a demo for now until i
decide to pick it up again i might do
other remakes with persona 5 and gb
studio 3.0 but no promises for now
we've been seeing a lot of fan d makes
or remakes lately whether it's
bloodborne resident evil 4 or persona 4
now but what's something that you want
to see redone let me know in the
comments and of course leave a like
subscribe and tune in tomorrow for your
next episode of gamespot news
[Music]
you